Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Let's
try Marcus from Manitoba, Canada. Marcus,
you're on the air. Hi, David. Hi. Please
make sure that your discord doesn't blink,
we've already heard one blink and
it's very distracting to everybody.
Speaker 6: How do I turn off the blinks?
Speaker 1: I'm sorry. You got to turn off
your notifications in your settings.
Just turn all sound notifications
Speaker 2: off, but you can go right
Speaker 1: into your question.
Speaker 6: OK, I've been I've been waiting
for a long time to do this. I've been passed
over every time. But anyway, it's going
straight to the question. My. Something,
something that I've noticed is sort of concerning
development that's really sort of been taking
place. I guess you could say across the democratic
world, but I think especially notably in America,
is this and I think this growing tendency
to view democracy? Well, there's growing
cynicism about democracy. Is this kind of view
of democracy as a sort of purely instrumental?
Device rate for the. And
simply sort of a means to the end of. Of
enacting whatever policies, whatever ideology
of a particular side wants to enact. And I
think this is a very dangerous development.
I don't know about you, but I was wondering like,
what? What what is your view of of democracy? Do
you think that democracy is something that is
inherently valuable at that is something to be?
Valued in itself, whether or not your side is
the one that is benefited by it or right, you
think that it is something that is sort of merely
instrumental value that's only valuable if it
enacts policies that we know that we like that.
Speaker 1: I gotcha. I don't have either of you.
My view is so my view is not that democracy is
valuable regardless of the outcomes or regardless
of, you know, I don't believe that democracy is
Speaker 2: valuable for its own
Speaker 1: sake only. And I don't think that
democracy is valuable only as an instrument
that allows my side to win. I think that there is
an in between view, which is we can have a number
of different systems and there could be a
Speaker 2: system that is a good
Speaker 1: system, even if my side doesn't
always win. And that's generally speaking,
my view on democracy. I don't think democracy
is valuable for its own sake. I think democracy
has a lot of problems. You go to, you know,
read Socrates on democracy and, you know,
a lot of fair criticisms of democracy. And we talk
about many of them. A lot of incompetent people
get to participate just like others
Speaker 2: who are informed.
Speaker 1: Outcomes are sometimes bad. It can be
system can be corrupted, etc.. So I don't think
it's valuable for its own sake. At the same time,
even when my side loses, it doesn't make me think
we need a dictatorship or we need authoritarianism
or whatever. I do think that on its merits,
it's the best system we've come up with so far.
Speaker 2: But that doesn't
Speaker 1: mean it's the only good system.
I'm open to another system being better,
so it's I have an in-between view on that issue.
Speaker 6: OK. I think that's a very reasonable
perspective. I. It's something that I have noticed
among like obviously, it's very blatant on on,
right, both in the U.S. and in in various other
countries that like, you know, they're not even
really pretending to care about democracy anymore
or they're they're pretending, but in just such a.
Transparently cynical way. Yes, absolutely. If
you.
Speaker 1: OK. All right,
I guess he's got a good question. Interesting
topic. That's going to do it for calls today.
We'll talk to everybody again very soon. Sorry,
I wasn't able to hear from everybody today.